and welcome to yet another stop on the
Dragonball fighters world tour here for
the 2019 2020 season we are San Juan
Puerto Rico I am rich this is Romanova
and we are here at first attack I'm
excited to be here I this is my first
time in Puerto Rico oh yeah
things were getting wild we got a lot of
really good players too that came out to
this this is a 10k each event
yeah we're winding it down right so
everybody's try to get those points all
the big US heavy hitters are here of
course some of the European competition
as well you mentioned shanks and wah-wah
in the bracket to people that are
looking near and stoppable especially
wah wah and then you got like knock yell
and Achilles aged and subatomic sabers
and super noon and Nakia all kind the
crazy folk from the US as well yeah I
was saying el padre esta aqui oh yes
he's in the building so we'll see a lot
of really fun Android 18 and we got
people that came out I think also from
Japan and I think a word we got some I
saw Itachi Cowell on Twitter yesterday
trying to get them games in he's trying
to get done I don't know if he got the
games I saw him playing with apology man
they were doing some stream sets that's
right yeah so I just I just really hope
that apology man got his Puerto Rican
currency that he was looking for oh I
hope so too you know was cursed about my
situation alright so I got here pretty
late last night I got here at 2:30 a.m.
I got to the hotel about 2:45 a.m. the
first person I saw was beneath Oh I was
like word I was like this is how you're
gonna treat yourself before games age I
mean 30 a.m. worry it's alright I guess
he got that currency bid they handed it
right they handed of his actual money
for those who don't know they handed
them his actual money right back to him
actually took all the money they gave
her and then put them back in the
envelope and then gave it right back to
him yeah straight up the milk there's
cold milk he's not finding any warmth so
it looks like we got our first match
here on stream pranking God
that's a little that's a curse name
right there Frank speaking cursed and
hook is nowhere to be found so talk
about this man is streaming he's
probably restreaming right now chance to
hook their dog and we got odio choco I
was saying I wonder if he's part of like
the og boys from Florida I'm not sure
where he's from but yeah the only until
we have that he's from the United States
so I think Florida is a good read right
not too far from Puerto Rico
about a two-hour two and a half hour
flight
but he's got the I don't know who but I
believe it's player one that has the the
fitted Vegeta and Goku shirt on I see
him I see him right quick gone quick
game call crank Pingala yeah from the
super movie okay the handshake we're
going into this so we're gonna be saying
a lot of teen gohan today gonna be
saying a dancing in it because he is
definitely risen when it comes to the
popularity in this game do believe the
kill stage definitely it was one of the
the people of that like he always
believed in the character right so as
soon as he got something that made him a
little more cheap like the auto combo
just going every which way trying to
chase you down no matter where you go I
definitely think he implemented that
back into his game and then a couple
other people that I'm just like not
we're calling up top my head at the
moment that has definitely been rocking
with a teen gohan for a while yeah you
got that squared
you got that square button unlock you're
getting obscene Brooke the guys take
advantage of the wards of the light
button in this game Bardock teen gohan
there's a there's like Canon be can in
here like team go on his real dad
oh yes and base goku and base vegeta
against each other like this today we
got a long way of tracking father boys
want to get to the axe you're going
checks are over about that base go
listen we see how strong it is ryan
force wawa decimating every
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go super dad forget to banish
out you have to get out into the beat
while takes it down to double axe head
I'm going to spark real quick go to a
super Dan Craig $8 press event super -
[Music]
maybe it's a lot of nerves here but he
gets the final hit they're killing teen
gohan taking about keeping it oh he was
actually living a little game of getting
clipped by the delay tree
[Music]
it never is no longer go back in there
oh yeah
I really know how scary the notice on
the front I was leaving the other side
but gets clips on a Windows computer
yeah like you've definitely caught
traffic but they're hurry we're setting
up the held every day
Oh sparking good job getting out of that
I definitely agree with that yeah I
don't mind students Martin right there
nice long and beheld a bandage and then
again
Oh chocolate just trying to hold up it
it put low sparking sucks helping save
some of his world like
[Music]
yeah you have the beat and the Piccolo's
oh poor Brian you can super - through
the piccolo or not so much the beans so
because we low into the sky I mean of
getting playful says the shank on the
ground being covered by that coming out
my house
oh I like that super neutral portrait
yeah I mean is there any other kind of
neutral on your plate Super Saiyan Goku
that's fair Chinese definitely fair
but yeah I'm taking it down with the
news set up shop Wow catch the super -
good I wonder if this has been a pickup
I am not familiar with a player I've
noticed that a lot more people have been
going bad at the base vegeta subsonic
Fox's picked them up yeah I think solder
telling some of the potential to
characterize maybe some people believe
me nice hit the first day just following
up with the auto combo made sure he was
gonna miss it
going into the Senate not going to be
enough to kill thought he was gonna up
tech there yeah it was definitely
reading enough Tamara top it was taking
the tip of ground this barbecue road I
could go yeah he already spent his super
- right so a smart tag Super Saiyan Goku
eyebrows we're going into our first go
to level 3 of the day
it's definitely with the tongue medium
right there didn't have it already man
Frank a God has tried to blink
constantly right so the real good job
our taco just stand consistent with the
pressure right there hanging with the
key blasts from fullscreen knowing that
he's gonna want to move I started with
the five eighths trying to send a
message
oh there we go you got the hitch
see if you can extend it there we go
Auto combo from here just tracking your
prop straight get the legs in here no
matter how far you are
we'll cover that distance crank didn't
want to deal with team go on to the
corner also he are sparking like
floating over pickle opener got to age
however he does get the snap out I've
just set up shop with the helicopter
NATO or they catch the chocolate Ossipon
sparking this time
on the ground both ways is available
adding that damage on its lucky tag okay
fantasies out of the corner there but
man he was like I'm falling with a fire
I can still press this and it pays off
for the kill on vocals yeah no drop on
that phone at this time so great finish
there for the Kiki reset right there
next to him so he get the dragon recipe
there and I've got the kayo candy coming
home and that's going to be the end
thereof piccolo
both players
Beach ho choco though sitting on that
sparking bill - super - it gets hit by
bass jito that's a good look for Frankie
God here as plenty of meter we can get
the smash knock down off the knees
okay sparking not one of the old face of
Judah in the corner I like that yeah the
vocalist is ready as well he's gonna
have to be more Gregory try to start the
class up and do super guy through sorrow
okay fate we face Goku out of there
basically with this we've seen so much
the work in the last year I think with
face go to especially with wall on and
how good that assist in general that
move is so probably a good character to
get out of the way if you can we're
gonna have enough for a level three here
from Vegeta oh let's get that extended
meter building the toss-up I like a
galaxy breaker yeah
what's the to age tracking is often
lights here all of these challenges
beats out the dragon rush has closed
price $10 we're gonna get rid of that
base go crazy
I like that directly change to get that
unhealthy character
bring out dad okay backs off a little
bit gets hit by the air keyblock here
this could be a dead teeth go on both
definitely still beat the smash knock
down to the teleport fish and then the
Kamehameha to finish it
now base Goku all alone those parking
does have one meter to his name
Oh complete with the 2h right there but
I'll take it anyway great Gengar piling
up the first set just like that yeah got
opened up there by that 2m at the end
first first game of the day here we're
going to a game three so I'm talking
about early action we saw otaku played
very well in that first game in the
first game here to the other in the
square I was he was telling me to shout
out to the Atlanta Atlanta boys school
to go there and play Marvel 3d at every
final round yeah look there's a great
dude gerrae find yourself in a mexican
tournament definitely hit him up you
know all the food spots he has very
hospitality and he's here in Puerto Rico
as well
I respect it just a little bit not
dropping as much as you want the first
game to finish off Barna already out
here literally got three green balls on
the side well get started without 5hr
they're cutting the air oh who the super
dad to em right they're too far away
grenades to the center
Sparky try to do with my eyes how's the
[ __ ] you get the full combo as well
yeah this thing but how long okay there
we go
we almost secured the hit there got to
jump it
yeah just kept them locked down with the
blocks then right even though you miss
the capo make sure he goes down
Chavo already sitting is sparking it's
early and he's hungry
and he's a five-point we can proceed
myself that's what I'm saying I'm trying
to get some of that earlier everyone
close their food pics get out is
everybody jealous
yeah totally goes
flatbed of the air the whole lot of
blocks line i slung the six and child in
that there was a demands hearing with
the - oh you always got to love the
jacket ears it's like the best feeling
to of something super deficit and you
javelin super dad oh yeah speaking of
super - you today rather keep the corner
man that Facebook was this is good we
get this privet are you want to go on
the air not today not what Bates go
through out there
yeah we got to hit there with that jump
heavy for the key black that should be a
couple behind
and I'll talk about just one character
great getting God with the Spartan
available as well as a commanding lead
[Music]
that she got punished for that drag drop
study with yeah was the second in the
article as well so you can see plaid
damage on that wow that's the stress
buzz at the Buckman sparking in the air
he's negative but challenging regardless
calm down two agents headband she then
gets thrown flick to the two head
footage right there get another VM
starter that means Goku is dead does
very smart
but what a comeback there yeah Craig
honest did your commanding in that third
cave but the base Goku bringing it back
rub mushroom Oh taco at the end right
there right both players look a little
shaky throughout the set but rifle able
to clutch it out in the end
yeah I thought that there was a really
good mix there of you saw Frank and God
adapt for a second and his piccolo was
not dropping nearly as many combos if
it's the first game and then in the end
it just wasn't enough
no most that I'm gonna beat the base
cooter and I give props to me and you
for still talking about that after we
just saw hockey out that in front of us
I was a little that the theme of today
might be cursed yes here nah keels just
dabbing at me I don't know what's
happening here but I've got these couple
to the stage now the snack dad the snack
that oh man yeah I'm not sure if I'm a
fan of hers snacks yes indeed I do I'm a
normal human being I love me some snacks
I need some horror Rican snacks man
well speaking of some snacks we do have
nappy out like we said going up here
against get good get good I was
sponsored by get good get good with the
Jay go Jay go on was the junior so long
maybe maybe maybe he please t go on that
would be appropriate right but we're
gonna seen a key L rockin the adult
Gohan which is always very exciting I
love this Panda goal but jersey by the
way panic will always got some sick
jerseys that's a good color blue yeah I
like that blue I like that better than
the they've had the green ones for a
while and then they had like red ones
but I think the blue yeah realizing
between kozinaki Oh step up to the plate
as well knock yo I think someone that
has not had the results that he's been
looking for in the saga offense but it's
the speckled it's not a taco van he's
always in the upper echelon of the
results so we can see if he can get
together here in Puerto Rico try to get
some of those big points on some space
as well get toward the center of the
screen
he almost 1c otaku he would side he was
in winter side of Grand Finals but box
was just able to make that come back by
the looser side that's what I guess
roomate like that if it's gonna be some
would make sense that it's your roommate
that you probably do play with and they
probably learn your bad habits you know
and then knock yo leave just won this
week's next-level battle surges as well
in New York City I believe Lord Knight
got second place Lord and I also here in
San Juan Puerto Rico from first pipette
yeah we got we got a lot of heavy
hitters Lord nice out here we were
talking about to kill stage no commie
came out oh don't call me the Builder
best
finally made it out to a tournament I
know he's been not feeling too well like
your dial so it's nice to see Alucard
out here again yeah definitely he's been
on the stream grind as well so I know
that I love contemplating and work with
a come to dragon ball fighters hoping he
has a fantastic showing here in Puerto
Rico well right now it looks like we are
getting into a boat players got the game
face on knock the Elvis Jay Quahog
course Nakia on the second player side
playing that cheap cans as he should
he's been so consistent with the
extensions on that goal harnesses of
course should be a surprise rise in the
rocking the adult ball haunt around the
game's lifespan
[Music]
kid who and you go through you are just
locked people down
[Music]
doing work at the kid boob instead of
this milky it's just so controlling and
then again the whip into the star as one
of the best would punish both in the
game especially after the flex with the
style we've seen how effective that is
set the game always great choice oh the
staredown swish dog taking out this
Bardock look I like it perfect right now
yeah yeah knock y'all set up the FB
jumble oh I get the credit for the
perfect you definitely want that yeah
something's gonna get you a little bit
of damage there and that too it's gonna
open up up there he's got three Firefox
- Zoe sea level 3
no level three hold on to those one more
copper with a finished it go home but
can't you throw pledge to the dragon
Russians old not gonna switch don't go
home back in actually just gonna take
the dampers on the kit blue again not
gonna get the corner
okay and hits the hit here with kick
booth horse is a specific ball to extent
it's not a great thing about kid foods
that you were to get the scrambling hits
it on the bag that's into the to age
baits out the super dad and that's gonna
be in five bars on the extent of the TR
super GT Goku and outsole
it's still much very bleak there because
there it is knock y'all closing out game
one here I assume he like called Gohan
for the super instead of GT Goku and
Gohan was still out there for the assist
yeah didn't get the secant everyone
look may the cross up here with Donna -
yeah this isn't work
jump in early at Wow mom vote off that
go Hawk to pre-emptive super dad just
had faith in a Hitler and even if it
doesn't rise Varzi blocks he's gonna get
a mix on after again
get somewhat overhead there you have a
2s and once he's in the air air air -
cancel into the overheads Jay call Hawk
on he has no rules you never really do
up at this quickly
here really good choice but Java
scenario oh one of the five is what the
palm there
[Music]
doesn't matter
yeah you go for the real awful stuff one
of that jump leaves bring them back down
to what it says
look at these legs go on never skipping
leg day
yeah something like that on the corner
but does not look good now forever at
all I like to wake up it's a back - with
that 5/8 right there you committed to a
heavy recovery moves and because of that
Nakia able to punish it on wake up and
it's all over - old - panda global zone
good stuff cannot yell looking real
clean and crispier in the first round of
Dragon Ball fighters at first attack
2019 that's how he's gonna need to look
if you want to take home a pad chuckling
yes he's really solid but we'll have to
see you know it's gonna be a lot harder
when you play especially those people
that knock y'all plays a lot in the tour
you know when a scale has to play like
you know Lord night like the other day
that that could be a potential upset
right so we're just gonna have to see
how it unfolds here today
but exciting news we were talking about
wolf to her and now up on stream we are
going to get wolf coming all the way
from Mexico
yeah the wiretap is in they are
listening to the commentators throughout
the venue and they are bringing wolf to
the stage forest they get from Mexico is
traveling out here foot boy or to Puerto
Rico for first attacks where I get some
those Dragonball Fighters coins get into
the Dragonball Fighters world tour which
of course is happening in beautiful
France I can't wait for that yes I
believe in France once and it was like
10 years ago so hopefully I get to go
back it's definitely quite Sevilla
country I enjoyed my time there yeah
parlez-vous francais how many languages
do you know
no that's like all the French I know I
do know Spanish previous though which is
nice because I'm in Puerto Rico right
yeah I've been like actually like
low-key getting a little bit better from
watching the Barcelona fighting streams
saw like kwangin tune in and just from
like listening I'll remember words that
I learned from when I was in like high
school play so woof-woof wait a minute
he remembers the casuals we played so if
he plays the team that he was playing
last night we're gonna see team going on
brawly's and Super Saiyan Goku that
sounds right I believe that is the team
he usually runs in tournament he likes
the big bodies as well yeah I used to
play hacker and Marvel so Broly
obviously in that felt fit for him but
he's looking at the big bodies in this
game and Brolio breathe dangerous
character right we seem to kill saves
you want thunderstruck with the
character we're gonna see if wolf puts
it down as well keep o sharp you would
like these two players but you know
where they come from right this is fun
is he wearing a shirt with geo on it he
most definitely is and we got the pulp
fiction shirt on the other side man I
just watched Pulp Fiction the other day
what a throwback this is why all right
so we got wolf versus king crab yeah I
was when I was playing I'm not I'm not
gonna lie we played six games oh great
I took one oh yeah what was good and
they and they were like you're playing
the team of the father he's trying to
make everyone at home oh that's right
you be like in the vegeto - I forgot
that was it you know well so he played
team go on and then he he also plays
vegeto he switched when we were playing
so he plays both so we're gonna see he's
gonna start it out with the potato right
of course the obnoxious pressures of
this character can bring a really punch
straight the opponent has a very long
blocks trees again that 5l somebody hits
very active is like a pretty committal
booths oh right you do present at the
wrong time you can get punished pretty
easily yeah just from seeing his play
style last night what he likes to do is
he likes the plate vegeto as much as he
can out there and he will throw out that
Brawley assists first and then you get
locked down with the puck flight legs
the little tap dance there with GT goku
beam on deck so you're gonna have to
deal with that pressure on the side of
king crab there you have to imagine
that's the strategy gonna see on the
other side Brett rubbing apart off to
give you an abroad least we got polio
all right there dumbass don't grow
NVIDIA judo too
Jewish animations here or out to 8spike
roll
it's literally getting kicked in your
face
the map was all this body weight on that
one oh is this sent to the sky an
ice-cream man crap into the chest pump
afterwards to ground fog off this town
if I use a b-boy get brownie more break
there we go I think that kept you in
paralysis basically by me when he fits
pun in so many times now and the three
said
by an effect at the ground balconies on
that word Oh shucks effective for the up
tanks not going to give too many more
say - that's one thing I notice when I
did he crab trying to sneak in that
cheeky body switch good see it I want to
go into it okay super
and catching him with the chump Alex
tried to get though rebellions BAFTAs to
ageless ah how that works
- eh - woof oh yeah Kent super nothing
in his crap really beats the top secret
in this mafia box do not take that will
you have anyway we got pauses these sync
your controllers both of their both look
at each other like come on wolf look
into the crowd like why are you here
he's like there's been one stream match
to stream matches why are we already
getting pauses I'd blame Nike oh but he
doesn't play a pad yeah obviously king
crab coming from the skull grows
background both of these players really
enjoying the team aspect of the games
right but we have a controller situation
that seems to not be fixed just yet so
they're consulting with one of our TOS
make sure everything gets going as it
should be Xbox 360 controller from wolf
I forgot about that
although the Marvel players like to use
that controller yeah I noticed that
it has the adapter and everything yeah
yeah he was trying to tell me to go back
to Atlanta and tell my boy damn he was
like make sure you tell them that Iron
Man sucks and I was like man you're
trying to really bring the shade here
you know but it's a great scene we're
talking about all the Marvel boys and
like and I was I was explaining that
that is how I got so good at Dragon Ball
was from moving to Atlanta and playing
with those old marvel people that switch
to dragon ball yeah like those people
leveled me up so fast like black work
dat VIP and Chewie jazz raps crap
Vermillion all those people are just
amazing players I don't actually think
Scott played marble though but
regardless strong scene and he knows it
but yeah once the install the iron man
though coming from those games where you
can call us this right in the 3 to 3
background they're just so good at
playing the neutral in
the environment that it translates very
well correct all fighters are just used
to managing assist people with the
longer cooldown that it says having this
game compare down to verses games
absolutely it looks like we're finally
going back into the game here had to
take a minute to fix the controller
situation that we had yeah I don't know
what the Bluetooth devices I didn't see
anything shocks but I was going on maybe
king-crab plan this he was like he told
her buddy like you know do you think
your pad so if I'm looking exactly three
minutes game to taking advantage of
wolfs hospitality that we talked about
it earlier I can always play again
that's no big deal
and we'll see him king-crab though you
thought it was a decent but it was me
the king-crab channeling desert
the building status
[Music]
just out there spacing from one alright
his staying out of range that acidifies
like not many people I think are gonna
adore me when that challenge gets
spotlight was there not for superheat
ground welcome to come down funds I'd
like that fossil beckons the corner nice
and early
all the to hand starter us big damage
lock down all the way lock down cost of
massive beaches bark on for the killer
is Danny eater again man yeah that is
just over judo right as soon as you wake
up he just goes jump as with the folio
since missed the arrow - mix of app back
[Music]
up tech or vanish out it can be honest
right baby you gotta also plays vegeto
people just grab you out there rolling
right there because the chump gets all
level one
the long lights on Brody right whether
it's 200 or 500 on the horizontal
distance on those we will interrupt the
napkin craft down this just one he
started off with a ferry got owned by
the same spirit he's trying to really
like force and scrapple pace I'm a
workout newspaper cetera but ta was all
right back here they start the wiggle
the ends up getting caught by the
students its head and force go forward
all right you got a present for up level
three
I was a set up afterwards all the late
streets very very drab and the key good
stuff indeed wow that is quite the combo
he has with a shirt and a hat I must say
good stuff the work we'll be moving on
in winners bracket as we move along here
first attack on this Dragon Ball
fighters think I usually stop Pedro
almodóvar I'm good I am I'm hydrated
I'm fed I had some great breakfast here
in Puerto Rico best part you know
shoutouts to the cafes the local cafes
at the cafe con leche did you have like
a beautiful view as well I feel like
it's hard to go anywhere around new
about beautiful yeah I found some stray
cats oh yeah this is like a family of
stray cats and I was like why are all
these cats together and then I saw the
culprit somebody must be feeding them I
found like a big thing of lingham food
in a bush that like minor like water and
everything so yeah these stray cats they
were there they're cool cats hopefully
they stopped by yeah yeah okay San Juan
Puerto Rico we are here first attack we
already had donkey on stage are you have
local onstage and now we're gonna have
Wawa from France on stage how could I
not be excited
Viva la la la oh yes indeed for some TK
breaker now voila I'm sure all y'alls
are tuning into these at saga and these
Tenkaichi events that wah wah has been
just record shop and he's been an
amazing player one of the most inspiring
dragon ball fires players in the
business in my opinion yeah I'm sure
like
EU is going wild right now in chat yeah
I mean he's gone public Tobago eg he
looks like he is top 3 in this game I
would say so
oh yeah
sokka torment yeah he took a controller
yeah no oh my gosh what was it it was a
tournament where DX d GX indeed it was
and shanks beat Sonic Fox there yes yeah
yeah that's right that's right that's
right Big Ups to Wawa there's no holiday
today of course at the base Goku but
this man knows how to play like the
entire cast right which is a very
beneficial and pretty much any fighting
game you explore don't kind of play all
of the cast will put you in the mindset
of what your opponent wants to do no
matter who they're running so because of
that wall well I think has a good read
on his opponent a lot of the time knows
what the characters are capable of and
he is just looked like an expert when it
comes Dragon Ball fighters and I've seen
a TK breaker before I'm not I can't put
my finger on it but I I'm familiar with
this player somehow I'm trying to like
figure out what tournament or whatnot
that I have ever seen this guy on a
stream he's up a crystal pendant I got
our key focus then of course Bob also
recently sponsored as well so Big Ups to
his sponsor as well you will see it on
the screen I'm unfamiliar that's why I'm
not saying it just yet yeah we're gonna
see the base Goku from him he's not
playing any games just yeah this is
gonna be the usual squad we'll see when
he's most familiar with the opponent all
the times he'll run a different team
probably hasn't read on his opponent
with what they're good at dealing with
and oftentimes heel counter it but right
now he's going with the usual stuff when
we
we got the base Goku yeah well we're do
60 days Goku and then the Gohan and then
the Super Saiyan Goku in the back as
well I feel like almost everyone at this
point has switched from I think at the
beginning as the life of the game like
year 1 a lot of people were using Super
Saiyan Vegeta as their anchor like that
was the most common anchor I felt like
we saw for a while and now it's the it's
the year of Super Saiyan Goku yes people
have gotten much better using beam
assists and then of course the Vegeta
says at the beginning I'm a knight you
had to use it so good has to receive
some changes ever since right I think
it's still a strongest is but definitely
not what it doesn't do what it wants
when it comes to baseball and he was so
fast there too of getting up making sure
that each button
wah-wah test them early right do you
have an assist the company just wanna
see out tkip treatment would react to it
he react up a little bit too late
three bars on deck with the extension on
the go through just like that the pose
yes possible way and Wawa is a scientist
right he throws acceptable topples he
needs to to touch you as you can see
just like that
[Music]
voila dominate this game is wala to get
a dramatic finish
I think business name than you can
against the base medida with base Goku I
want to say don't quote me on it okay
but I want to say I think this is one of
the ones that has a dramatic finish
between every presence from P beginning
and here we go welcome in the way that
base Goku moves you right it's very hard
to tell where the goal how I'm gonna end
up end up wasting the cross I can see
every law afterwards do every side every
side that sits covers think you gotta
block high soul unfortunate man TK trees
breakers function all something that's
so much fear on that dragon runs
extension
- of wawas fast balls like
every assist going out if he wasn't
going to have stepped off bit from a hit
he was just fast falling to try and get
like a two adders nothing in there
we got the base Goku time to put on a
show for the fans the shining star of
the show here we got go to Black Rock
back here benches does not expect off of
that perfect wall would oppress the bus
the wall against the head
to get a pair of old man suffering the
autumn combo while always got something
it punishes it that invulnerability on
the teleport elbow gets caught bandage
shake by that fist there and while it's
right with the two weeks so you knew if
you didn't get goodbye the SS he was
still getting punished Wow we tried from
the elbow right there stay in the air a
little bit longer so that to avoid it
jab them out of that right there the
prison in the air right there's a wall
walk take advantage of that extended
blossom there's over the 5h again elbow
down there too close and out wall up
taking a very convincing date one here
little stuff like that just shows me how
like the much wah-wah is not auto
piloting right when he just gets the
jump back and punished into the spark
like he's never just like he never has a
game plan and he follows through it to
you right he has adjustments based on
what his opponent is gonna do at all
times
very very dope to see you he's very good
at situational awareness and just being
ready
yeah that's Wow he's one of the best
players I've seen in Dragon Ball fires
when it comes to stuff like that see
she can't breaker taking some time I
like this no need to rush right back
into it switching up the squad heavily
as well oh wait wait a minute
[Music]
interesting so look like he was going to
keep the base lagina on the squad but at
the last second decides against it I'm
gonna bring it the Goku black back out I
still really like blacks it's
interesting to see cell played on anchor
and played on point for sure yeah that's
something I feel like almost anyone that
played cell he's either he's usually on
point I feel like yeah most definitely
cuz so uses a sister so well right yeah
and a lot of time he needs it just to
make his point a game function very well
but instead he's gonna be on the able
position we usually see Goku black and
an assist spot because of that be hi
[Music]
[Music]
every single extent like you still have
time to go food just to get the dat back
in and going on to get that level of
killing even with the meter scale no
super necessary
[Music]
he's so awkward every year this year
both of the assistants tension a look at
the Dragon garage put so in a position
where he's gonna be all alone in the
corner doesn't have to be pitch he can
play cartoon at all
smash knock down the back fist
sparking out great we're just trying to
get something suppression off of him
some breathing room finally it's a hit
here but you get a hit on wall I got a
count now
yeah he was not able to optimize off of
that ok Wallace Park Justin I have to
deal with that probably the risk is
looking in a good position here hits the
vanish hole
[Music]
it's the nares - anyway it takes all
down like knock sell right over the
dough and sending him into oblivion
figure the meters wouldn't kill on that
last takes the two I mean we call him a
scientist a game won right using the
level of that extended damage from Gohan
then it's a Goku then into the spirit
bomb perfectly calculated that describes
wall want to achieve yeah and that's it
this kid just goes and he yeah he just
goes and smiles and he's just like ready
to have a good time shaking hands so
that's how it gets down man you see him
make quick work of his opponent I'm
sorry I had to do that to you yeah he's
like don't worry many of bodies will
join you in this bag that I just put you
in so we'll see more of that in a little
bit but we are taking our first break
here on twitch.tv slash Dragonball
Fighters don't go anywhere as we
continue with the action here at first
attack
let's go she's go hon go hard I gotta
see the very advanced age doesn't pay
him anymore
let's go overhead my turn and he jumped
up so deftly his paper thank God for the
safe jump oh the load is tied to the
legs so cheap to the leg it's a legs
okay to parrot a done like hotcakes
Finnish dance Wow say bread I looking
ridiculous right now smoking that boot
early on and that's one huge part of the
others on no more assists
then what look down yeah that's true
brownie powers up let you bet oh okay
super that's right it'll be good
reaction day from the water let me play
it super special it gets burly very very
wrist like that for breakfast what's for
breakfast Oh wake up need me i ad sage
going to work right now Bofur are
looking a bit flustered in the chest
my notice look up freaky but the post
before the super come on go monitor city
okay sage that man I see the aura
surrounding sage right now he ain't
playing no games oh my god oh he was
shot ahead of a flying kick spawn oh my
please kill him lay right there the
defense will display Oh like father like
son
absolute little bit much as you can got
both assists yeah quick circuit so cool
weather yeah yes is definitely one of
the most on example gonna grant yes
without that I like how stays back soul
just not even apply that precious adored
I don't have sparkle there there's a
force anyway
Wow pretty the buddy good good Marissa
steps H :
Matthew against every time you see that
stagger like that just always match the
toy it was a good thought you forgot
that a lot of people forget actually
[Music]
what is the rapid fire
you might get a a reflect a treble
overhead is gonna be the challenge right
there for you sage no great just trying
to mix I can happen try to force a
situation or just this is how stupid -
combo Oh see them swipe it again no you
know glasses crooked boat yeah that was
a rough that was rough that was rough I
don't blame you I don't blame you yes he
was like yep I'm going to take my
lashings and I'm gonna get up out of
here the kill/save holds on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to first attack 2019 me and
Romanova right here chillin for the
Dragonball Fighters tank IET event
players trying to get those points
trying to qualify for the finals we just
saw wah wah and now we have the other
Titan of Europe coming up el padre
indeed so we are going to see some
Android 18 action which I could not be
more excited for and we're bringing back
up here OTO Chaco who we saw take out
crankin god earlier yeah very cool set
between himself and crane game God now
he's got a whole different beast to deal
with look at the BGI a shanks healing
from Spain of course put himself on the
map here and specifically in this Dragon
Ball season he was doing work last year
as well but man he's really coming to
his own here in 2019 yeah he's gotten a
couple top aides too so yeah I mean on
this tour he's sitting pretty with a lot
of these points mm-hmm just needs to
secure some more I think he's very much
a strong pick to make top eight year but
there are some killers that he is gonna
have to go through in order to make it
there yeah like last year you wouldn't
be too surprised that he made the top
eight this year he's a favorite to make
every top eight he's at so shanks again
tested himself up against Oh chocolate
again this is a top 32 winners qualifier
matches Wells who are moving along
nicely in the bracket yeah I think the
first time I saw shanks really make his
debut over here more more so was at
combo breaker where we work levitating
and and he may top a loser site there so
really great to see him still going
strong through the season of Dragon Ball
and we'll see how a choco here fares up
against the grand
father here Oh pottering around me we
shall see
well he move up the Damascus tearless
after this tournament we will find out a
choco horse plane at she came with his
own right where we got GC goku face go
through and then Super Saiyan Goku all
the way there
very nice isn't that powerful smashing
you are using super - so we attack them
to the face goku trying to beat out or
affleck right there
the beam assist or chocolate looking
strong here the opening to a piece of
damage here lashings tried to put the
late uptick right there oh my god just
lock them down with the elbows hold pop
this part checks don't want to build a
taco like that right both value of
momentum very heavily while heavily
ended up on the same side I'll follow
the fighting again that's twice now he's
hitting with that has enough here to put
him in the grave as well goals with the
kaio-ken he goes all the way through
that should be him there's actually a
little bit less than as ya like that
because GT beaucoup has a lower damage
level one just over to the level three
instead make sure the kill happens
things are not good here right off the
bat for shanks which I feel like we
almost have a different player here
right now a choco a little bit less
solid when we first stop please
great kick god it's like it's a whole
other person oh don't you the difference
once you start warming up right he's
looking very very good now but shanks
does open them up with the dragon rug
oh just get them about standing low the
shining star the show here all he really
needs is 418 to be out there we're gonna
go into the level 3 there's no parking
you get out of this still not the same
Effie you used to have but still very
strong still get the mix off of this
most definitely
all right behind is it'll vanish Yap so
it took advantage of it
what rises over the to age maybe hoping
that he was posting up the deer in a
block and we cannot jump chances into
the light and that's going to close it
out there for shakes even the playing
field
all it takes this character here it does
have a Super Saiyan Goku beef anymore
most definitely el chocolate still has
his right so he's able to comp all food
with the auto combo Wow delayed rise
into baking that to him will take
advantage of it reflects oh my goodness
now I would really like to see shanks
here fate a lot of these Oh what the
reflect punish those this could be a
dead adult going on here
leaving shanks only left with Android 18
this all chocolate he's not gonna
abandon that strategy he was just
backing up and reflecting even though
the first to win five against the third
and he punishes for the kill on shanks
is go home
shakez is going to need those barcelona
spirit bomba emotes going off the chat
to let him your energy Spain
right now those parking available does
have near six bars does get it after
that and guess the empty won't start off
now the good news is here is shakes does
have seven bars can afford this level
three going to get some mix off of it
[Applause]
keep your eye on the birdie we're a team
gonna be suppose to the double axe
handle is even call seventeen yet six
seven let's keep the hit advantage walk
that time there's even try to challenge
dr. Lepke shanks was ending cement again
so just committed to the 1705 switch
there the bandage that leaves the door
open for shakes a 2h bunnies yeah that
was a great opportunity for shanks to to
get closer now kind of have the light
feet and Bart bandage here
[Music]
last one here identical now Chancellor
slightly oh yes
trying to cover these with moves with
the baby gingers is blind and wait for
the 2h punished oh man that's gonna be
hit two dragon rush into the love of
grief tanks bringing it back after a
rocky start for the first game
if anyone's to do it it's gonna shake
I'm sure Spain definitely helped they're
lending their energy probably all over
twitch Ted yeah it was really a couple
of those whipped moves where he tried to
cover it with vanish that really got him
killed right there two two ages from
shanks and of course you cannot give him
those opportunities right he's so
familiar with his characters he's so
good on his characters that he's going
to make the optimal punish happen hey
you're gonna die I do agree here with
the taking the breather here at the
screen this might be the kind of you
know a little bit of a reset or chaco
mental reset going right yes maintain
your composure and he did I'm not gonna
lie like I said it's like we saw a
completely different player here for a
second compared to the first game that
we saw a choco play yeah I'm surprised
because he was doing so whether he
switched the team where I take him out
GT goes who put it on the bar doc I
think GT Goku was actually doing pretty
well for him like on the team like I
feel like that team ran smooth against
the first game yeah by that much I think
you could get the same thing
lift up at the super - make some shanks
not thinking he would just go with the
dragon rush and finding it anyway there
sir
yeah choco just try to reflect and
because of that change spying and way
punishes the recovery and that's a dead
fart off in an instant goes into the
grab into the level one that is that all
the damage he needed and of course
because we killed a character that means
no scaling for this leader even
building all that again if any absorbs
the BB saw meter let's go oh yeah it's
got the DP assist for Beaumont there
the wild there's no pollution to that
afterwards knows he can't go Boston like
that how he used to himself off the Goku
assist yeah shakes was ready he was
ready for that
because it's a beautiful extension I
forgot about that
it's not everyday you see that is also
why shapes probably will always tell you
that this team if you're trying to go to
team around get ready to eat this is the
team to build around hurt because they
just all breathe synergize so well
together
Wow I even use the links right there
this in case it is predicting the key
blast and supernatural if I was so smart
okay the walk up jab gonna get that
dragged across off of it smash knocked
down again you have level 3 yeah this is
another way to reset the momentum of the
game slow it down a big put the level 3
out there get some damage and a hard
knockdown always lie that way trying to
bait out of DP but she couldn't shown
that man yeah beautiful just in there
that's about as he lands
yeah that jump light it security forum
sitting on a lot of here
go to the Sancto into Android 18 level 3
like that bring Android 18 back into the
fray notice is available here but he
does get the hard knock down the box
that's the mix cross up jump medium
there that's the thing that frees them
out of the corner enough to hold that as
a threat and sheikhs takes advantage of
[Music]
a one-character away from advancing a
much different story here in game 2
shanks and complete control the whole
time maybe you just took a little bit of
time there fore shanks to find his
footing to get this player you know try
it not to really underestimate news
playing against no matter who they are
for sure
very smart approach to the game from
shanks I like that delayed uptick as
well oh it does get clip holding off of
the 2m I do like the spacing here that
Oh taco is just going fast off a little
bit and he's gonna pay off here not
gonna fight built that third bar there
but
yeah because it was baseball he has
access to that like double level one
super I wonder if he was gonna look for
it but hit up whipping right before you
got it you the way that's not gonna
matter cuz Chang says enough leader look
this base boku away finishes the combo
cleanly as well oh yeah and that is
gonna be in el padre takes it over a
Chaco they're gonna be moving on the top
30 to win aside which of course is a no
surprise for Chang so one of the top
eight favorites here at first attack
2019 so we're gonna see him more a bit
later
yeah we'll definitely see a lot more of
him again I think he is definitely one
of the favorites here today to make top
8 but we have coming up next subatomic
savers or I know I know you're a fan of
subatomic savers I remember when we were
commentating a combo breaker this year
you're like Gillis my boy yeah so I feel
like every time I say that he does
poorly okay your father does boiling
this time yeah not mine my curse yeah
yeah I remember and I think we'll see EO
you came up on stream I was with the
masses I was like no the mask is this
guy self atomic sabers you've never seen
combos like this man has I know you guys
got shanks that wah wah and all that but
this man is own thief and then he just
got washed and I was like well you know
see it be like that you talked your
smack and he got whacked but the worst
part was that he like dropped every
combo like I don't care if you get
washed but I was talking up your combos
and you drop a ball hopefully we don't
see that you like mine Kirsti like his
either pattern stick whatever you plays
on I can't see right now how you play
Compaq okay subatomic pad player I
believe the next box 360 pad player once
again it's going to be a flip the cap
around okay
is that like when you're like ash yeah
yeah the business time okay he knows
he's got to bring the business if he
wants to be some atomic safes that's for
sure summer Tom makes one of the Rising
Stars of Southern California always top
three at WN f every single week one of
the things that subatomic will obviously
have to watch out for that we saw wolf
doing earlier as again that up tech wolf
has two characters on his team that are
ready to just catch technically three if
you think about the GT go to assess
because it's a diagonal B yeah I think
I'll catch you in the air too so you
really can't up tech against this team
he can toss you in the air from vegeto
he can grab you with Roly it is just
gonna be quite the time but we cut a
vegeto mere get ready to tap-dance folks
oh yeah Gregory Hines all across the
screen coming at you if you like that
subatomic is this hmm I was gonna say
subatomic this is his main squad okay I
was gonna say he's still rocking the go
tanks yeah not too many people still
rock those tanks yes Wow right we see
more sell to both agencies Wow
yeah there was a time where Boateng some
colonists came here every team but that
time has long passed right the first
blood here they get that hand and take
it to the corner we already see what
he's gonna do here toss him out toss
them back to hit their track to 8 save
yourself there with the cell assist
against the head 5 light yes of the
common customer Lee got the 6m overhead
says wide-scale 3 har then toss him back
into the corner again to the drug rush
to get them out get GT Kokua talking
about a strong character this season
Jiki joke who has been something that we
have seen almost replaced like how we're
talking about goteng but we see almost
every team especially on the top level
having this care girl there on their
squad to eight from go tanks to still so
active yeah absolutely still
don't hit box on a lot of active frames
and now we're gonna set the post op
although to Asians reflectance that I
picked up at optical surprise that will
tested about that
for solar flux starting up in one frames
while you need for to get that air and
vulnerabilities in the 2h yeah great
defense here from woke though but it's
not gonna be quite enough find an
opening here subatomic savers going into
the beyblade and that's the baby put
some of the topic savers will put you in
such involve offsprings he gets away
with stuff like that where he does the
things green vanilla sis behind it all
the blue feed that not taking time you
think of that GZ go from right back in
okay great tech here from wool super
duck is
great reflects to the depends on this
man is wild right now o2h though trying
to manage it yeah committed to the
vanish but subatomic was able to fall
from the beam and they're punished
because of it yeah well if I think that
little bit anxious right there's Wanda
start giving some offense of his own
Zuma blocker for a whole lot of time if
it's up rocket okay it's cut from the
parolees super dad you're gonna go right
to the level three set myself up for
supporter positioning here
most artists Chuck a 5ml overhead held
vanish into the combo
didn't have to watch out to while being
in this corner though you can get fuzzy
by a small character both players
content the block it out subatomic
partly fighting he opened up with the
overhead plus the ghost that means he
didn't have to use his assistant
afterwards and he's gonna get the kill
on pros yeah go into that super donut
there
well he didn't have to really worry he
didn't have a lot to worry about what
that goes so he was out because he also
didn't like he knew as the pump didn't
up sparking left so he was gonna spark
out of it what's he gonna do reflect
when he sends them out yeah that's the
thing right he just sitting there is
very good for some topic because he
would be out reflective a tout Vantage
or even just being out at a convention
yeah it used to be but it still is so
good set it up once again here I stand
there like a bad date to I think before
it was like almost too strong blogs
shout-out to the balance because I first
up a lot of players actually that this
current patch even though we clearly
have certain strong characters that this
is like where they perhaps the most fun
for the most part playing the game yeah
all scream that of what he saw were
applied to what an adjustment by
subatomic savers right they're good
people to kill as well with the
extension yeah even wolves to the press
without one how did he resent man he
responded to getting reflected with the
screen be and that was wild cuz he knew
that he was gonna commit with vegeto to
the 500 afterwards see it might it might
have broken this curse that I was one
that said that joy as long as you don't
say it I think he's gonna be okay hey I
might have gone a little bit too hyper
the infant who knows
wow it's a wolf and then they extended
horizontal range on that 5l like
tippy-toes like the full foot somewhat
stomping love the downside to age
smash hold onö smashed on that that
actually will spark up get out okay give
the hit there when he gets down to the
ground yes so the topic I think you know
looking for perfect a grab a ton of data
go to the other side either a Isaac lock
down too hard
yeah right up to that final comment help
me not
and the hard knockdown the spicy very
high in the air we got reflect notes on
the tag he was just waiting there I
thought oh that's a wolf is looking for
OS right there the van jump up it goes
right into the sword
yeah it feels like the start with the
two lo2 and this town for seven top ants
a medium starter here
yeah those rings you still lock you down
without a parable in the gimmick by
those we talked about the leader built
our vegeto that's gonna be enough to put
down ta wolves old vegeto all the way
through to the ghost can only be one and
that is so the topic savers vegeto
now you got two healthiest character in
as well Philip who locks in to recover
off vegeto I like that doesn't want to
tussle with a parolee at the stalk
around
couple of like both it's this here are
diagonal for him as well like that words
clear okay here we go
yeah we're gonna snap we're gonna bring
in GT Goku those four below yeah a
chopper up his legs on the top is got it
on 28 wolf wants to draw a defense right
before this hit you got to get off
Brawley just back up and punish the two
Oh challenge with the junkie blast
now he claims to work for flex takes the
hill on the goings but yeah it's not the
topping to play those things for a long
time it's getting hot to follow it up
well we think that should block the
seller says he's too short
barking hey I love that reading the hit
early he's gonna spark up to ensure the
kill here have to use the ghost kill and
that's gonna be it they're down to his
last character things not looking very
good here for wolf sometime this is
another top 32 winners Paul matches well
some fancy stuff right now I try to get
a little bit too cute little challenging
it's hot now the command grip
yeah the to a trained duck man grab that
is some beefy moves they're going right
into the level three here won't the
delay but I just want to get the mix of
afterwards does connect the mix-up
gray stuff from wool same F shop and it
pays huge dividends
I really like the link use that there
you don't you don't get to see that too
often I feel like a corner
no super spot right you do the level
three when it comes to a capo wasn't so
he just uses it to set up another raw
hey kind of beat out some stuff again
subatomic but didn't block well long
enough sometime the savers little one
takes them down it takes it to over wolf
and he'll be advancing in a winter side
top 30 to this stuff from subatomic
coming all the way from Southern
California and I don't think that's the
last obviously that we'll see a wolf
bullets you know both did a really good
job they're keeping his momentum even
though he was definitely at the
disadvantage there so I feel we had some
really good moves he did with Rowley
yeah but didn't really get the chance to
breathe over subatomic sabers vegeto
yeah definitely the in that matchup it
was the superior vegeto on subatomic
saver side yeah subatomic I think that's
definitely his squad the geocell go
things right to characters that we don't
see too much anymore at me because you
know we don't see that much either so
it's just really the characters that
he's gelled with the most and has put
the most time into leading up to the
Savannah he looks so comfortable
whenever he plays absolutely
looks like we have not yell coming back
up here to play again 30 top 32
qualifiers like we were saying and I'm
not familiar with his opponent neural
arch neural arch in her art I've not
previously heard of this player myself
but I'm interested to see how he fares
obviously the first game that not yell
that we saw him on stream he was getting
he was definitely the more he was
definitely dominating that game
yeah it looks super clean which is what
knocking out knee is right we talked
about he's kind of underperformed at the
drunken ball fires tour event so he's
one of those players that needs the
point needs to come through here in
Puerto Rico at first attack trying to
qualify for the finals that be taking
place in France so we're gonna see I
believe he'll be also be at the Japan
song event as well as the Spain soccer
event so he's gonna be going to all the
tournaments as far or as many
tournaments as possibly at those points
yeah it's very exciting I I definitely
do believe I saw him tweet that he was
registered for the Japan Saga that'll be
a tough one that with being in the home
of some of the deadliest dragon ball
players scary you got go Ichi got tachi
khalwa you got been rich Naoko the names
known in when it comes to the house
Japan is you just pull out the paper and
it just goes all the way to the floor
right yeah exactly like all those guys
right and then we have like Margo taking
a taking notice as well a lot of the old
soccer boys okay so fine no okay stop
mocha has moved off to this hole and so
there's a who is it that plays vegeto
over there
it was pakka for a while it was a while
ago this dude beat lesson with vegeto
and teen gohan no no it'll come to me at
some point I know your chat already
knows we're talking about this will be
na ki o versus Lera knurl art as you
mentioned in the USA vis Porto Rico
alright let's see if he can defend the
home turf here against Nakia from New
York
yeah Nakia from New York by William
Seattle recently moved I guess not so
recently war he's been there for quite
some time he's been all over he even
told me at a stint or he was in Georgia
for a while oh yeah
yeah cuz he knew all like when I moved
there he knew all about the locals there
okay the Gwinnett brawls and everything
I'm sorry give this is it leather top 32
witness qualifying match Nakia vs neuro
artist kid who looking like a great
all-purpose walk or not he'll actually
the interrupted that DT Goku and then
get past a stop because the air can't
quite pop over to GT Goku assist all
feel like so beginning of this always
evaluating your opponent I feel like doc
yells is trying to find that opening it
does kind of a great with runners on the
whip rebellion spear at the air
[Music]
we reflect there though and you see
knock Yola Justin I know my code is goes
with a super - afterwards and then
you've lost the spark you dip back in
the air though so he wasn't so he's
gonna press button will reflect punish
though with that to end
- oh nice - H this time I'll cancel
again of course
Garnett's our interval to everything but
aunty air property music I feel like you
a lot of these players that we see
dominating the tournaments here are top
players they are always the quickest to
punish these parts consoles that people
do so you've got to really be careful
yeah knock you know all this is sitting
in opponents doings I think instead of
that - a little reckless with the top
extreme super - yeah a little surprised
sir he has this long walk but he did not
cover himself like super - again not via
health advantage for a little bit like
he delayed the vanish so I didn't get
the wall bounce I just call what off the
assist are you serious bro and then you
have passes into the 2h off the 2l my
goodness he is looking like a boss there
here gets the extended combo as well for
you can even land
he's got for the sliding knockouts on
and off the chill goes but look at that
the policy hanging on for dear life gets
jabbed over the head with that light to
jump light very impressive play from
Tokyo so far
but [ __ ] you can people find that
opening here max rains on that final
smash down look we know this takes
another want to get the healthier
character here that's smart
it's gonna be a little bit of damage
buff to you here right oh yeah powered
up level three is gonna take him out of
the corner but he's gonna get some mono
P office yeah out there it might have
been a little bit of trouble for on the
but he did the right thing there yeah
fresh jump a hell but it was like right
over his head so I didn't actually make
a block anything man just blocked out
again we talked about how good Nakia is
that using that gohan assist that's one
of the best distance of the game of
taking someone from the sky for the
ground yeah this has much range like
vertical vertical range that's some of
the best properties and assists can have
obviously key to go through lending
himself to that as well speaking of GT
go through here he is wreck right now by
not yells kippu Sparky
not yellow for bars I'm gonna need all
of them go to the level one go to the
level three closeout big one here game
one going to not yell even a little boy
only thing that's really changed good
stuff yeah he's looking super impressive
in the first game and as well as his
first set that we saw him on stream so
Nakia continuing the momentum his
opponent to the corner as well you know
that lockdowns coming next
you called it there it is maybe trying
to jump I didn't see any counter here
they did get clipped by the to the kid
blue level three yeah knew the triple
level one who is do enough damage so
let's take the hard knockdown to get
through it
[Music]
that blue house parking meter yeah not
y'all had no beater take advantage of
that Vantage gap there so he tries to
reflect afterwards no are to the proper
region except the condo their feet so
the level one rated as long as you level
three purple city birthday I like that
right there new he preserved the - or
you get the old yeah afterwards
yeah uses parks on the down jack there
are can I look at this an air - we were
to be looking for him as well is the
mistake though when it's closer and hit
a little bit by it side switch great
defense here though neural arch getting
traffic to the corner with this golden
pressure goes with the heavy legs
and now both will since our back all did
not recover from that the reagent side
butter
this putting the legs out there I could
have a wall
right now don't go on these be the
exterminator and get rid of the ring oh
isn't a good start here
it's gonna get the full cheese
yeah ichigo who does fall out after the
auto combo grass almost enough to do not
bother to extended clips optimal is here
he's gonna kill off the dragon rusty it
- wow the presses still trigger the
sparking as well complete control for
not at the second hit of that final
catches them and he down text button
gets the auto combo as well my goodness
i'm just showing off at this point
switching snap out brings Bardock gotten
ahead with the chuffing life
level one from Gigi Goku things are
looking very good here for knock yell to
move on to winter side of the top 32
here and ease Quahog players is always
looking to show off yo GT go through
this time we'll finish 50 you puck the
spark number 1 oh yes to all the panda
Global's knock yell get hit wah wah man
they just have these extensions in these
compo situations I've never seen before
and they're just so comfortable with the
characters super safe their masters go
hot they are they truly embody the
essence of a super Sam we really do it's
really fun I one thing that I'm not
really good at is how they how we saw it
in the last set with na ki l is doing
the different side swaps like when he's
like going up doing the combo and that
gets on the other side they receive the
auto kampala side switch like that
either
yeah that's like something that I've
seen a local from Georgia scrapper
millions online but I know it's like a
little risky sometimes in tournament
setting that you could that's like where
you risk like potentially dropping so
you can show off but you know we might
not see it in a match maybe versus like
sonic box yeah I think that's a great
point is that knocking I was very
comfortable right now Ryan he feels like
he can get away with some of the swaggy
stuff that he's doing taking a bit of a
risk just you know feel good about
himself kind of pump up his morale with
the cool stuff he's doing but ya up
against somebody like a wah wah or
shanked or something like that I don't
know if we're gonna see that but not you
know is one of those players that likes
to like treat everybody the same in a
way when it comes to his game plan right
his confidence level so he might he
might try that stuff we'll see yeah we
will see a lot more out of him obviously
already looking strong trying to make it
into the next step which would be top 16
so indeed so we're getting another match
here in a minute but for now you guys
gonna kick it with me and Roman over
here on the dragon ball fighters dream
of course this is first attack 2019 one
of the last tink ing stops in general
for the Dragon Ball fighters torso again
players are out here trying to get these
points coming up soon is the Spain saga
event that after that is the Japan saga
event so we are wrapping up the tour
here for the 2019
season yeah it's really cool to see the
way that they changed it up this year
last year was about all the dragonballs
and this year is the saga and
technically each events really great I
know a lot of people were really happy
about the change of the point system
this year and then we also will have the
finals in France yes it is to be
determined right but you know we'll see
a lot out there last year was in
California you had the pleasure of going
there right did yes yeah California my
homeland yeah we got to hold the World
Finals there last year but again this is
a World Tour right so I'm a big fan of
that moving into France moving into
somewhere very far away from California
make sure that everybody gets the proper
representation and you mentioned that
the format switch to the tour this year
yeah if you're unfamiliar with how the
Dragon Ball fires tour went down last
year it was all or nothing at all the
saga events right yeah you either got
the Dragon Ball and you were qualified
for the finals or you got nothing when
it came to qualifying for the finals so
this year of course it's a point system
the saga winners do automatically
qualify for the events but there's only
three sagas there's the e-vote of the US
and then we have the Spain saga coming
up in the Japan saga all three of those
winners while I'm at the qualify of
course goiti already did automatically
qualify but there's also a faction of
points related to those events that is
and that's how we're gonna determine the
rest of the bracket I think besides the
last spot which will be determined by an
LC q at the finals and that is going to
be really exciting to the Spain saga I'm
sure is going to wait it's going to be
all the Barcelona guys my goodness the
crowd when it comes to Spain and a lot
of your tournaments in general are just
so electric right so I can't wait to see
the Spain saga take place and the whole
crowd of the players everybody back in
there boys and the girls it's gonna be
awesome
and I'm sure France is gonna be exciting
too yes oh yeah oh yeah if I were to
have to learn to go I would definitely
make sure to hit up some food spots but
I also don't know
game is there so what I would do from
eyes when I was a France like I'm the
picky eater so I'm not like too
adventurous you know but they had I
don't know that they probably still do
but they had these bombs street vendors
they had the homemade waffles with a
Worman to tell it right call line cook
is how it was going in yes hazelnut
goodness
speaking of treats we have a team here
with Android 18 and Android 21 and
cooler the back cooler I don't know if
this is a me team or familiar with Fox 9
7 1 but speaking of France out here
prior from France so you know we'll see
him at the finals at the very least if
he doesn't qualify he'll be at the LCQ
I'm sure so we're gonna get into it
cause TK breaker we saw her earlier so
we actually seen him going with the
order we expect him to go in right to
get breakers bringing the self at one
point in the gopis laughs back to the
Akers can't reverse those roles last
time cause this is real very interesting
very cool here for any try to grab well
after the absorption on the vanish
good talking to Gary
down takes into the look like it will
get them out of there for bit but leave
it to the Vantage right back into the
corner you go guess top lockers for a
little bit there okay quarter finish
almost
[Music]
okay banish that overseas and raise 21
there yes three into the ground covering
it up for each one's a very underrated
character right now in this game and you
don't see as many people playing her as
you did at the start of the game yeah
most def con this is funny because they
did change the way and we were like
ability still works right you don't keep
them permanently now but they get bump
all of them she's one of those
characters that place the tag out method
so well she could like literally do it
on
so we got the cart camps one here
bringing in cooler swing enemy I wasn't
this cool breeze of the table beside
ping pong TK breaker fighting opening
here we go Black Bolt bah humbag he's
gonna hold on to all of them they'll try
to kill him this next combo the uptake
into the dive cake is a popular way to
see the corner wood cooler but can be
put right back into it there's enough
here to kill a buff this time
[Music]
with the bump paper that level watch
them go through black it does a lot more
damage down
I say that like it's a news think that
that bump is like at least like two
packs ago or something yeah but we still
see a lot to go through black rice I
think good good point super - and is
gonna do it reset there we are
scrambling he gave birth to NFL level
one but why not make up a donut and that
one is going to be completely eaten oh
yeah chocolate sprinkles all the way
through yeah the only thing that could
make that don't know better if it was
the strawberry frosting with the
speckles yeah
oh you know I love the same thing yeah
right at the very least the whole don't
tell the commander at the last second
[Music]
good thing he didn't call it the system
that would've been game Android 18 does
fall to the level three though see game
breaker showing the ring for the first
time I think we've seen all say our
alternate what beat me boy
yes whole lot of beef in that ring
that's like some grade-a it's a Wagyu
yeah some top-tier beef yeah simple Gogi
some behold a man not be careful who you
say that around I know that spicy pork
bulgogi all day okay I can get down with
that - I can get down with that you
right now you get breakers looking to
see who's the oh I say actually 971
France from France looking to see who
he's gonna bring back out looking like a
go cheetah or you get our first goal
Cheetos a day
alright I like it this is a it's a
pretty cool team actually teen gohan
base go through of course on the rise
both of these characters on the rise
when it comes to the popularity teen
gohan thought to be one of the top three
characters in the game and then on the
other side got go cheetah okay he's
pretty good I feel like there's still no
general consensus really for this
character yet it's still
ooh yeah and pretty new being legal in
tournament as well I think there's only
been like one other maybe big events
that he's been legalized yeah definitely
a few few number of Dragon Ball events
that he's actually been eligible to be
playing at so I'm gonna see if he's got
any goji de shenanigans of course he's
got the command we're at the course
we'll go back s gotta be careful of that
pretty decent assists and we you've been
playing or doesn't help both sides but
it's not like this scam this is just an
all the way across the screen wall
balance kind of similar to base go
through in that sense gonna have the
wall balance looks like almost like a
dive down
oh I like that delay on the uptick right
there I have to avoid the mean situation
that bring a try the toys that mask the
town but do not get that anti-aircraft
reframes time Wow straight up perfect
attack head to the uptake we're gonna
give us all outdoors
[Music]
so much glue life on the cell yeah so he
wants to get him out to wait so the gods
their monster age from across the screen
right there consulate on the incoming he
has these two moons on deck with the
Vegeta and Goku just the shoot across
the room
because going up with the jump you
trying to follow there's a medium right
there you end up getting eclipsed by the
Hugh glass nice the late uptick again I
really like the defense that Fox is
presenting he's just fun to dancing with
that jump media using the three hits
from him TK breaker trying to keep
yourself away right now from his Gogeta
oh the punish there
very very smart move here gonna build
enough meter almost no gonna go with
barriers I swing it toss him down he's
out of here rip go cheetah
yeah local where the vanish Mehta has
really evolved ever since they increase
the back - need a lot of time not lazy
fat - out when they get vanish so
because of that they have opportunities
to with hunters 500 people just try to
oppress them
that bp2 age again to break into the
level three
always little bit need be again that's
gonna be all cool I understand I like
the choice that he keep once in this
mess already but I feel I feel like when
you take it up you aren't expecting it
but when you do get away [ __ ] yeah see
game breaker able to heal all that blue
line with the sparkling pop Oh even
bending it out for a second walk back
for that jump into out there hit that
square TK breaker able to get to the
other side
Oh actually class with the atacama love
that song gives the raw egg look at two
particles vanish bring him back
there's taste the back that that time
called it wiggle it
kiss the counter hit extend the auto
combo yeah that's gonna be a heck of a
drop for up here things not looking so
great for Fox but a great jumped out
again behind me to Papua super Dallas is
I like that point therapy TK breaker
okay after it no he's actually punch
this with the jet I like that not
risking the auto couple third hit this
is quite more as on so you just cancel
it
not gonna kill though I'm gonna be able
to escape out but tries to move it get
spot from the canceled
Auto combo nation baby yeah reckless
management a game breaker right there
gonna loss box to get a clean punish
Kostas still aloof this match though
especially with the teen gohan down
[Music]
right Fox is not in a good position
again but I mean one bar on deck the hit
oh and that could have been in because
normally that move anti-air - you know
[Music]
super - is great back off there
Wow guard cancels away so anybody's game
at this point
oh boy I got your turn I think he was
expecting really like punish him for
back - you can go that's on the way the
banishment has evolved really really
interesting right because along the time
players will leave their old lands - or
chase you down to the bat - but this
time to impress a bunch challenging it
immediately
it's not a good day to be a tomboy
in the corner now though this is
available Oh Agis after the legs all
confirm with the go cheetah yeah though
the first of all back wants to burn off
that something else but what TK breaker
isn't really food with is growing
especially when he's in the corner UPS
is trying to bait and do the backs down
that's something I see surface of
royally players use a lot like ASAP
rookie yes a separate to use it that a
lot
take them out
yeah it's great stuff using the HS super
for Gogeta in the air - he one block
that the spirit bomb try to go with the
as he invite house the ground is a fire
balls start off wow that he p his
football a patient here a little bit
spot there at that catch young he's
gonna catch him all the time with that
building
they take this bow he gets up afterwards
rolled to Evitts so good at catching
wrong tack as many who did not convert
off of it out no Boris would step down
but this is gonna be the opening that he
leaves here really like I'll see game
breaker played that situation right
there
Fox going with the upset does enough to
get out but he's been up in the middle
but can't convert for the kill zone
fortunate does give the corner all tried
pinching your recent but I'll take that
we don't have it try to beat up there
too
a blood drive back for PETA's animation
reflected Superboy
Oh opening crack Samantha's own
go back to the wall back here
versions
[Music]
look at these animation shoutouts
absolutely love the game keep getting
better tastier there's not a real good
job of stacks on the Goku black fresher
Fox probably unfamiliar with the batch
up at this point and I used to fighting
go for blacks nowadays yeah crunch it up
with the 660 not gonna quite do it
though
volcano gets up on the corner
momentarily Wilcox immediately with the
backpack
[Music]
beyond comprehension this time not gonna
fill the two bars and meter scale is
it's been heavily but the law I will do
it Fox takes it after the switch to go
Chino well done
hopefully we see him at the France LCQ
if he doesn't qualify for properly I
don't see why he wouldn't yeah in from
France oh I got short to the LCL if you
can show up when it's in your like
you've been even exist
alright that's best fact that's fair I'm
a little sensitive to that because like
California is huge so people are like
why don't you go to open wnm I'm like
cuz that's a six hour drive originally
from Pennsylvania okay way back and like
beat from Pittsburgh people will always
be like oh like Philadelphia and it's
like it's the same thing
Philadelphia's literally the other end
of Pennsylvania six hours away
see I'm biased I think all the Northeast
takes like two hours to get to you
that's just how I feel if you're on the
East Coast
yeah that's why it's 10:00 in Delaware
East Coast all the way use clothes right
get to New York in two and a half hours
I can get to Philly and a half hour okay
I could get New Jersey and like us or
two hours why that's Baltimore in an
hour
that's pretty cool three team in three
hours is nice so hopefully we see Fox
over at the France Italy at you but for
now we're going into more losers top 32
qualifying matches is going to be neural
arch who we saw earlier going up against
sinister grin now we saw it was not yell
take out there oh yeah we haven't seen
sinister grin yet the info we have the
insult we have is that he is also from
Puerto Rico so you got to Puerto Rican
natives here battling it out to make top
thirty to try to get some of these
points here at the dragon bonfire think
I eat you bed for first attack 2019
thank you all for joining us at home or
from wherever you're watching you're
gonna get a break after this match we're
gonna have save damn step in as well
we'll keep serving you some juicy
Dragonball Fighters matches though oh
yeah all throughout the day well I just
noticed the ceiling any other lights are
crazy
beautiful venue in a beautiful country
were taco has been fantastic so far
absolutely it's humid outside though oh
my goodness man I went outside for a job
this morning I had my what you got you
got to come back to the three showers
you can tell like you know us Dragon
Ball players we don't we're not known
for our sink yeah we're we're fresh so
if we're jogging in this humid way we're
talking earlier and as I went outside I
first had my glasses on just so I didn't
have to put them away my glasses were
completely funk as soon as I stepped out
in the air-conditioning completely
fogged I could not see I had to put them
away I was gonna say yeah there's no way
you survive a job window wipers in
installed on my glasses being in Puerto
Rico clothes drench glasses fall but you
made it we are here in the
air-conditioning at the corner and the
pressure just appendix a 5/8 Instagram
thought he would drop the decal COO
[Music]
corner always night that the stalker he
is dead Android 16 just like that
barely 20 seconds have gone by the point
carry their sinister grin already in the
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
great popular clap the bow he's got that
sidekick s about the glass VP always to
mess you up while air-to-air in him but
either way to get the dragon rush open
up yeah that's a very bold rack clutch
but I like it I like it
hit by the GG Goku beam though this
could easily right here he is dead
mirrors were going at the knock down
here from Bardock level one
zombies level one I'm not gonna get to
see where I've wanted to see I've been
saying it since Joe that everyone's been
making the joke that GT Gophers around
obviously
yeah you definitely never going to get
to make no it's something you don't want
to open up the purple light see one
level three black is still some of the
best in the game oh look at the little
Priss
finish it no takes out swaggy
sparking still active as well I'm able
to build a lot of meteor if he does find
a hit here not so much kick though did
get hit by that side kick almost like he
would make a fuss after that so hit his
jab is very aggressive out there gets
like knockdown probably going to level
one
no he's gonna hold it but it's caught by
the pipe life I think I put up on a
pixel so instead they hold on to the
meter but not gonna do him much good
smash lockdown is that why he wants to
get that's off the most possible level
Warren oh yeah
jump it right into the ground it did not
actually hit this is gonna hurt though
this is gonna be dead
yeah
oh yeah definitely killed if you hit
that level it's just coming to ruin your
day so the best things about barkis's
rise so fast rebellions grow on the
ground keeps them standing as well when
you're in the sky it's a great assistant
call and they're trying to maneuver
below you we dunk in the day boys cooked
right it's unfair starting off the round
16 already doing more work than they did
last six yes and the assist but back
along the horn is on the table without
one here's like walk the veg instead
their dad
[Music]
Briella be
love the box of beautiful
still just attune the full combo at this
point we're getting optimal over here
just explain
- wrong tag get that unhealthy 16 hours
again TV interventive to get the snap
draw arms have a loss right back use it
for a combo extension at the end there
that's the tech right there
your daughter transmission was instinct
but this rebellion Spears got a quick
starter now beerus back in point when it
comes to the meter he's just going to
tack about for 360 but doesn't block the
overhead wow versus level three but you
could jump that on reaction
[Applause]
yeah this isn't online give it after the
flag of holder to the god of destruction
of your dollar things are thought
looking go Fred to go pee decide if he
does it again
mine's better timing as you need to
level 3 set up shop what that makes
don't be
the Chuck bit there okay vanishes can
get himself out of the corner goes
redness and drag for us probably a
really good choice here probably wasn't
expecting it yeah we're gonna get the
beard fall out but right through it baby
yeah we're playing dragon balls
literally try to track it rush it still
blocks total from the orb so he's gets
5l before the death art takes it to Oh
qualifies and losers top 32 well done
indeed so that's been some good
Dragonball Fighters action so far here
first attack 2019 thank you all for
joining us here on twitch.tv slash
dragon ball fighters has been me and
Romanova bringing you the first block of
action movie got blocks all throughout
the day so if you're looking for more
dragon ball fires action do not go
anywhere and we'll be right back with
some more of action and a commentator
swap stick around